[Musik]
ein besonderer Tag heute für Deutschland
und die vom Krieg gezeichnete
ukraineski ist angereist in Berlin
Gesten enger Freundschaft und
gegenseitiger Dankbarkeit bei
Sicherheitsstufe 1 dann mit dem
Hubschrauber weiter nach Aachen dort
bekommen der Präsident und die
Bevölkerung seines Landes den Karlspreis
verlegen für ihren gemeinsamen Kampf um
die Freiheit Europas
darauf schauen wir heute aber auch auf
die spannende Wahl in der Türkei ein
ereignisreicher Tag natürlich auch mit
Sport und den hat wohl die Pferde für
Sie hallo schönen guten Abend als erstes
aber der Blick nach Bremen dort wurde
heute eine neue Bürgerschaft gewählt und
die Hansestadt wird wohl in
sozialdemokratischer Hand bleiben so ist
nach Prognosen die SPD stärkste Kraft
geworden deutlich vor der CDU der SPD
könnte also weiter den Bürgermeister
stellen die bisher mit Regierenden
grünen rutschten jedoch ab
die Zahlen jetzt aus dem ZDF Wahlstudio
vor Ort von Matthias vornhoff Matthias
nach der Prognose wir haben die Parteien
abgeschnitten ja das schauen wir uns
jetzt mal an die Prognose von 18 Uhr die
CDU 24,5 Prozent die SPD deutlich
stärkste Partei mit 30 Prozent die
Grünen 12% linke 11% FDP 5%, das ist
also sehr sehr knapp und fraglich ob sie
in Bremen und Bremerhaven über die 5%
Hürde kommt und die Bürger in Wut eine
rechtsaußenpartei wohl 10,5 % in
Abwesenheit der AFD die hier nicht
zugelassen war und jetzt gucken wir mal
was dieses Wahlergebnis heißen würde
fürs Regieren in Bremen da braucht man
für die absolute Mehrheit 44 Sitze das
amtierende Dreierbündnis SPD Grüne und
Linke kommt da drüber mit 49 sitzen eine
große Koalition die den Namen
tatsächlich noch verdient hier in Bremen
kommt auf 51 und ist noch deutlicher
darüber und falls die FDP dann drin ist
ginge auch eine Ampel
äußerst knapp mit 44 sitzen das ist mal
die Datengrundlage für den heutigen
Abend ja vielen Dank
es gibt also keine Hochrechnung sondern
nur eine Prognose fragen wir danach bei
kein Niklas er steht in einem Bremer
Wahllokal in dem gerade die Stimmen
ausgezählt werden warum dauert es denn
so lange bis zu einer ersten
Hochrechnung in einem endgültigen
amtlichen Ergebnis
ja ich bin hier in der alten Post wo bis
zu 600 Wahlhelferinnen und Wahlhelfer
die Stimme Aussehen es begann um 18 Uhr
mit den Briefwahlunterlagen jetzt kommt
die repräsentativen Wahlbezirke für eine
erste Hochrechnung um 21:30 Uhr ich
verstehe die Frage wann kommt denn warum
dauert das so lange es liegt nicht am
Bremer Bildungssystem so viel kann ich
verraten sondern am Wahlsystem die
Bremer haben nämlich jeder fünf Stimmen
und können diese Stimmen Panaschieren
oder auch kulminieren was heißt das man
kann die fünf Stimmen auf eine Person
oder auf fünf Personen verteilen oder
auf eine Partei und oder auf fünf
Parteien und das dauert so lange das
alles exakt nachzuziehen so dass gegen
21:30 Uhr erst mit der ersten
Hochrechnung gerechnet wird also ganz
schön kompliziert alles danke schön
keine Niklas
und jetzt gehen wir direkt in unser
zdf-wahlstudio dort ist Bettina
Schausten mit den beiden
Spitzenkandidaten von SPD und CDU
so ist es hier im Wahlstudio haben wir
die beiden Spitzenkandidaten die auch um
die Spitze gekämpft haben versammelt und
ich beginne beim Wahlsieger
SPD-Bürgermeister Andreas bovenschulte
ja sie haben wenn diese Prognosen sich
dann bewahrheiten die SPD wieder zur
stärksten Kraft im Land Bremen gemacht
wäre dieses Wählervotum mehr buchen
Schulte dann für Sie auch Bestätigung
ihre Koalition mit Grünen und Linken
vorzusetzen also erstmal freue ich mich
über dieses Ergebnis klar stärkste Kraft
und es sieht so aus als ob uns ohne uns
keine Regierungsbildung möglich ist das
ist erstmal aus Sicht der SPD gut und
wie ist dann jetzt weitergeht das müssen
wir in den nächsten Tagen sehen müssen
wir das Wahlergebnis erstmal vorliegen
haben und dann in den Gremien beraten
ich habe vor der Wahl gesagt die jetzige
Koalition hat eine gute Arbeit gemacht
aber wir gehen ohne feste
Koalitionsaussage in den Wahlkampf und
werden hinterher mit den demokratischen
Parteien reden und das was ich vorher
gesagt habe das machen wir dann
hinterher auch also jetzt mal abwarten
Frank Imhoff der
CDU-Spitzenkandidat beim letzten Mal hat
die CDU hier ja fast ein Wunder
geschafft und wurde in Bremen stärkste
Kraft jetzt sind sie auf Rang 2 und
bieten sich Herrn bogenschulter an für
eine große Koalition als Juniorpartner
als erstes mal gerade Andreas
bovenschulde ganz herzlich zu diesem
Wahlsieg und was heißt anbieten also wir
sind ja mit deutlich mit Deutlichkeit
stärkste Kraft hier zweitstärkste Kraft
in unserem Bundesland und ich denke der
Wähler Wille zeigt dass es eben nicht
mehr so ein weitergeben soll mit rot rot
grün sondern dass man sich um die
Alltagssorgen der Menschen kümmern soll
und dafür steht die CDU auch mit immer
in ihrem Wahlprogramm und wir werden
jetzt mal die Wahlprogramme übereinander
liegen und dann schauen wir was geht und
sie hoffen darauf dann schon dass sie
hier auch einen Wechsel schaffen denn
das hatten sie ja ihren Wählerinnen und
Wellen Wahlkampf versprochen ja genau
wir wollen natürlich mit regieren den
Anspruch haben wir als Volkspartei und
jetzt hat aber die Regierungsauftrag die
SPD
und wir werden uns dann ja hoffentlich
wird uns die SPD dann einladen und wir
werden dann wirklich schauen wo wir die
Schnittpunkte haben und dass wir hier
auch was bewegen dafür kämpfe ich immer
dass wir in dieser Stadt Veränderung
noch mal hinbekommen und ja dann wird
sich sehen Verluste für die Grünen
stabile linke eine FDP die noch zittern
muss und die Bürger in Wut als
protestadresse so haben die anderen auf
die Prognosen reagiert
lange Gesichter bei den Grünen nach der
ersten Prognose wird es wohl eines der
schlechtesten Ergebnisse der vergangenen
20 Jahre
für uns ein enttäuschendes Ergebnis ist
wir haben uns sicherlich alle viel mehr
gewünscht und das Kopf an Kopf Rennen
zwischen Frank im Hof und Andreas
bovenschultet das hat uns eher geschadet
deutlich zufriedener die Linken sie
kommen entgegen dem Bundestrend in
Bremen wohl wieder auf ein zweistelliges
Ergebnis und wollen weiter mit Regieren
in einer rot-grün-roten Koalition wir
haben irgendwie bisschen wenig
Rückenwind aus der Bundespartei gehabt
das ist leider so haben ein bisschen das
Problem gehabt das mit einem
Koalitionspartner den Grünen die
Zufriedenheit nicht ganz so groß war
betonte Gelassenheit bei der FDP dabei
könnte es noch eng werden für die
Liberalen laut ersten prognosezahlen
müssen sie um den Verbleib im
Landesparlament noch Wangen für den
Spitzenkandidaten aber keine
Zitterpartie nach aktuellen Prognosen
ist uns das Glück und das ist unser
gemeinsamer Verdienst den wir uns in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten erarbeitet
haben
bei der Wahl in Bremen wurde die AFD
wegen konkurrierender Kandidatenlisten
nicht zugelassen davon profitiert die
Wählervereinigung BÜRGER IN WUT die
Rechtspopulisten könnten erstmals in
Fraktionsstärke ins Landesparlament
einziehen wir hätten uns am Anfang das
Wahlkampfes auch über 6% gefreut jetzt
sind wir bei 10,5 Prozent und deswegen
geht als erstes mein Dank an alle Wähler
die uns ihr Vertrauen geschenkt haben
der Sieger des Abends aber heißt Andreas
bovenschulte seine SPD wird wieder
stärkste Kraft und die historische
Niederlage der Sozialdemokraten von 2019
damit wohl wettgemacht
ja und dann ihn noch eine
bundespolitische Frage wir sehen die
Schwäche der Grünen in ihrem Land wir
sehen dass die FDP hier noch zittern
muss was ist die Botschaft die hier aus
Bremen kommt für die Bundespolitik für
die ampelregierung also wir sind ja ein
Bundesland und haben deshalb auch eine
bundesweite Bedeutung und muss aber auch
die Kirche im Dorf lassen in erster
Linie ging es hier in Bremen um
Landespolitik und die Politik in unsere
beiden Städten und insofern geht
natürlich ein gewisses bundespolitisches
Signal dafür aus die SPD kann Wahlen
gewinnen z.B aber das Wichtigste in
diesem Wahlkampf war natürlich die
Landespolitik ganz klar und deshalb
finde ich darf man die Interpretation an
diesem Punkt auch nicht übersteigern
aber insgesamt ist es natürlich für die
Sozialdemokratie ein richtig gutes
Signal dass das heute in Bremen so
hervorragend geklappt hat das Signal für
die CDU ist nicht ganz so gut ja immer
auf ich will sie noch mal fragen die AFD
ist hier nicht angetreten hätten sie als
das CDU nicht viel mehr von diesem
Potenzial jetzt abschöpfen müssen und
nicht den Bürgern in Wut überlassen
dürfen also wir als CDU hier in Bremen
sind immer in der Mitte der Gesellschaft
gewesen wir waren nie auf der Seite der
Rechtspopulisten und wir sind noch nie
nach rechts oder nach links gerückt und
dass das wäre auch mit meinem Gewissen
gar nicht vereinbar gewesen also es geht
ja nicht darum das geht ja nicht darum
einfach nur eine Wahl zu gewinnen das
geht darum das Beste für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger hier zu tun und nur mit
populistischen Aussagen damit kann man
hier nicht weiter vielen Dank
für die und SPD die Spitzenkandidaten
hier im Wahlstudio in der Bremischen
Bürgerschaft zurück nach Mainz danke
Bettina Schausten und nach dieser
Sendung mehr von der Wahl in Bremen aus
unserem ZDF Wahlstudio
blicken wir auf das nächste große Thema
heute den Besuch des ukrainischen
Präsidenten in Deutschland vor wenigen
Stunden wurden selensky und die Menschen
in der Ukraine in Aachen mit dem
renommierten Karlspreis geehrt sie
verteidigten europäische Werte so
Bundeskanzler Scholz in seiner Laudatio
vorher war Präsident selenski in Berlin
die Einzelheiten von ultra und Julia
Reich
lange hatte Deutschland auf den
ukrainischen Präsidenten warten müssen
wegen Steinmeiers früheren guten
Beziehungen zu putin war das Verhältnis
der beiden schwierig gestartet hallo
Herr Präsident schön sie zu sehen sagte
ins Kino
Harmonie Offensive auch im Kanzleramt
selensky hatte Scholz zu Beginn des
Krieges als zögerlich kritisiert Scholz
fand das ungerecht nun stehen sie beide
auf dem Balkon des Kanzleramtes hier war
nichts und 1990 haben wir wieder
angefangen sagt Scholz und zeigt auf
Berlin Mitte
Wiederaufbau nach Zerstörung ist möglich
das ist wohl die Botschaft des
Bundeskanzlers
so lange unterstützen wie das notwendig
ist
verteidigungs- und Finanzminister haben
am Begrüßungsgeschenk für selenski
mitgearbeitet ein neues rüstungspaket
fast stolz sieht der Kanzler die
Waffensysteme auf
Streitkräfte werden weitere Kampfpanzer
vom Typ Leopard 1 weitere Schützenpanzer
Marder und eines die Systeme erhalten
der ukrainische Präsident will noch mehr
Waffen der Kanzler schmunzel deshalb und
dann gibt es selensky ein wichtiges
Versprechen ab
greifen keine russischen Gebiete an wir
haben dazu auch gar nicht die Kraft und
wir haben dafür auch gar keine Waffen
übrig mit denen wir das tun könnten wir
bereiten eine gegen Offensive vor um
unsere besetzten Gebiete zu befreien
zweite Station von selenski Aachen die
Stadt ganzem Zeichen der Sicherheit er
und das ukrainische Volk bekommen den
Karlspreis für die Verteidigung der
europäischen Werte Dank an das deutsche
Volk und den Bundeskanzler
als du Olaf die zeitenwände ausgerufen
hast hast du angefangen so zu handeln
wie der Verteidiger Europas handeln
sollte Europa wird dir immer dankbar
sein
Europa und Deutschland feiern Zielinski
in der Hoffnung auf Frieden
und in Aachen ist für uns energy sie
haben die Verleihung vor Ort verfolgt
wie fällt die Bilanz dieses Tages aus
die Veranstaltung hier in Aachen die ist
vor nicht ganz einer Stunde zu Ende
gegangen und ist ja bleiben von diesem
Tag zwei Eindrücke vor allem übrig zum
einen wie sehr selensky momentan auf
Deutschland setzt um die Unterstützung
für die Ukraine weiter voranzutreiben da
war sehr viel Lob sowohl in Berlin als
auch hier in Aachen noch einmal auch für
den Bundeskanzler persönlich aber zum
anderen auch ein zwiespältiges Gefühl
des offensichtlich auf ukrainischer
Seite noch da ist denn es gibt eben noch
den großen Wunsch eine sehr schnellen
Aufnahme in die EU und auch in die NATO
da sagte selenski hier bei der
Veranstaltung in seiner Rede sinngemäß
schaut euch an wie wir kämpfen wer wenn
nicht wir hat auch verdient dazu zu
gehören und dieser Wunsch der ist hier
von allen Beteiligten auch in den
öffentlichen Reden natürlich so nicht
weiter aufgegriffen worden und nicht so
beantwortet worden wie er sich das
sicherlich wünscht also ein Tag an dem
Europa die Ukraine symbolisch in ihre
Mitte genommen hat aber nicht alle
Wünsche erfüllen konnte danke für diese
Einschätzung
in der Ukraine ist die Auszeichnung mit
großer Genugtuung aufgenommen worden für
viele einer pellt durchzuhalten das gilt
auch für die Menschen im weiter stark
umkämpften bachmut im Osten des Landes
hier haben die Ukraine an den
vergangenen Tagen Geländegewinne gemacht
Tim Kröger hatte die Möglichkeit eine
drohneneinheit bei ihrer
Aufklärungsarbeit zu begleiten
irgendwo einige Kilometer von der Front
in bachmut entfernt Valentin und sein
Team bereiten die Drohne vor sie hat 50
km Reichweite operiert in 500 bis 1000
Metern Höhe beobachtet Truppenbewegungen
und hilft der eigenen Artillerie die
geben Ihnen die Punkte der Ziele dann
geben wir Ihnen die Koordinaten der
Abweichungen die Artillerie justiert
nach
Sicherheitsgründen dürfen wir keinen
echten Einsatz Filmen denn die Situation
ist angespannt nach Monaten der
Verteidigung stoßen ukrainische Truppen
in bachmut offenbar erstmals vor
unsere Moral natürlich sehr und
gleichzeitig zerstört ist in der
russischen Thrones weil Gebiete die sie
seit Monaten besetzt gehalten haben in
wenigen Tagen befreit wurden die
Aufnahmen der Helmkamera einer anderen
Brigade zeigen offenbar wie heftig die
Kämpfe am Boden rund um bachmut sind der
Verlust eigener Soldaten liegt schwer
wenn du vor der russischen Invasion
Pläne mit der ein oder anderen Person
gemacht hast und dir nach einer gewissen
Zeit klar wird dass es sich in deinem
Leben nicht mehr gibt dann ist das
schwer zu akzeptieren
Tag was kostet und trotzdem machen sie
weiter und hoffen auf noch mehr
Geländegewinne im umkämpften bachmut
kommen wir zur Türkei wo sich ein
Wahlkrimi abspielt nach ersten
Auszählungen liegt Präsident Erdogan vor
seinem Herausforderer
dem Kandidaten des oppositionsbündnisses
aber das Rennen ist noch vollkommen
offen wir schalten gleich zu unserem
Korrespondenten Jörg Brase er hat die
neuesten Zahlen vorher der Tag der
Präsidentschaft zum Parlamentswahlen
zusammengefasst von Anna Feist vor der
akp-zentrale in Istanbul laufen Sie sich
warm zum großen Siegeszug hier sind sie
sich sicher der Chef wird gewinnen und
die Osman kommt zurück in unser Land
und was wenn nicht
wir werden Ihnen das Land nicht
überlassen was wird diese Nacht bringen
eine Frage die die chp-vorsitzende von
Istanbul seit dem frühen Morgen umtreibt
sie glaubt an ihre Partei das
Oppositionsbündnis um kilotsda aber
fürchtet die Wut der Erdogan Anhänger
diejenigen die nicht an die Demokratie
Glauben sind in der Lage alles zu tun um
den Stuhl auf dem sie sitzen zu
zerstören den Tag wird sie deshalb mit
einem Bodyguard verbringen zum ersten
Mal in ihrem Leben denn die
Sicherheitssituation für Abgeordnete der
Opposition sei sehr angespannt so zeigen
Bilder den Oppositionsführer Kemal
College der Rollo auch heute mutmaßlich
in Schuss sicherer Weste abgeschirmt von
Bodyguards an der wahlurnee in Ankara
unterdessen inszeniert sich Erdogan
warten mit Personalausweis und Enkelkind
als vorzeigedemokrat im Wahllokal in
Istanbul bis 17 Uhr konnte gewählt
werden die Wahlbeteiligung sei so heißt
es bereits überdurchschnittlich hoch zum
wahlabschluss ruft Erdogan über Twitter
dazu auf jetzt ist es wie immer die Zeit
die Wahl und zu schützen schützen sie
weiterhin den Willen unseres Volkes bis
die Ergebnisse feststehen wenig später
twittert auch der Herausforderer
verlassen sie niemals die wahloren egal
was passiert bis der letzte
unterschriebene Wahl und Bericht
zugestellt wurde
überraschend früh gibt es an diesem
Abend erste Hochrechnungen die sehen
Erdogan von belastbar sind diese Zahlen
jedoch nicht
quasi in zehn Minuten Takt kommen die
Ergebnisse der Wahllokale rein Jörg
Brase wie sehen die neuesten Zahlen aus
also die staatliche Nachrichtenagentur
an der Dolo die meldet nach Auszählung
von angeblich rund 40 Prozent der
Stimmen das Präsident Erdogan mit rund
12 Prozent vorne liegt vor seinem
Herausforderer kinderolo wir gehen davon
aus dass diese Zahlen beruhen auf
kleineren Wahlkreisen die schnell
ausgezählt werden konnten was im Moment
noch fehlt das sind die großen Städte
das sind aber auch Städte in denen die
CHP sehr stark ist wie eben Istanbul ist
mir oder hier in Ankara die CHP selbst
hat eigene Wahl beobachtet ja an allen
Wahllokalen die melden an die Partei
zentrale ihre Zahlen und die sehen ganz
anders aus da liegt der Wohnung mit 48%
vor Präsident Erdogan also das wird den
ganzen Abend noch so weitergehen dass
ich die Zahlen ständig ändern da müssen
wir wirklich noch abwarten wie knapp ist
tatsächlich wird fest steht aber jetzt
schon dass wir eine Wahlbeteiligung
haben die noch mal höher als diese gut
80% der letzten Wahl von fünf Jahren
also wir werden wahrscheinlich so um die
90 Prozent eine unvorstellbar hohe
Wahlbeteiligung haben danke schön Jörg
und mehr dazu und wie es weitergeht nach
der Schicksalswahl um die
Präsidentschaft finden Sie im Live-Blog
zur Türkei weil jederzeit in unserer ZDF
heute App
erst gestern war eine Feuerpause
zwischen Israelis und Palästinensern in
Kraft getreten jetzt wurde sie
anscheinend gebrochen laut israelischen
Militär wurde eine Rakete aus dem
Gazastreifen auf Israel abgefeuert
daraufhin beschoss Israel eine Stellung
militanter Palästinenser als Reaktion
auf die waffenrohr hatte Israel am
Morgen Grenzübergänge zum Gazastreifen
geöffnet damit waren dringend benötigte
treibstofflieferungen wieder möglich
israel hat am Dienstag eine
Militäroffensive gegen den islamischen
sie hat gestartet dabei wurden auch
Zivilisten getötet
der Mann Streik der Gewerkschaft EVG ist
abgesagt dennoch werden morgen viele
Zugverbindungen ausfallen im Fernverkehr
wird es nur zwei Drittel des üblichen
Angebots geben teilte die Deutsche Bahn
mit auch im DB Regionalverkehr wäre es
zu Ausfällen kommen die Zeit sei zu kurz
um alles so schnell wieder hochzufahren
am Dienstag sollen alle ICE und IC-Züge
wieder wie geplant unterwegs sein
Schweden hat beim Eurovision Song
Contest in Liverpool die Trophäe nach
Hause geholt und das bereits zum siebten
Mal
und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport die
Bundesliga ist ja auf die Zielgerade
eingebogen genau und zwar bei den
Männern und bei den Frauen die
Fußballerinnen des VfL Wolfsburg haben
im Kampf um den deutschen Meistertitel
einen Rückschlag hinnehmen müssen die
Champions League Finalistinnen kassieren
eine 0:4 Niederlage beeintracht
Frankfurt zwei Spieltage vor Saisonende
liegt der VfL 4 Punkte hinter
Tabellenführer Bayern München
Jubel bei Eintracht Frankfurt und
Trainer annautes tiefe Enttäuschung
dagegen bei den Wolfsburgerinnen
Spitzenspiel vergeigt und wohl auch den
Meistertitel die Frankfurterinnen
Hellbach vor toller Kulisse im großen
Stadion die Wolfsburgerin früh mit einem
Eigentor Eva zuletzt dran noch in der
ersten Halbzeit liegt Nicole ein Yumi
nach nationalstürmerin Freigang dann mit
einem Doppelpack in der zweiten Hälfte
Eintracht 4 Wolfsburg 0 Frankfurt im
Kampf um die Champions League sechs
Punkte vor Hoffenheim die Wolfsburgerin
wollen es am Donnerstag im Pokalfinale
gegen Freiburg besser machen
und in der zweiten Liga der Männer hat
Darmstadt 98 am drittletzten Spieltag
erneut den vorzeitigen Aufstieg verpasst
der Tabellenführer verliert bei Hannover
96 mit 1 zu 2 Verfolger Heidenheim
unterliegt Paderborn 2 zu 3 der HSV
gewinnt mit 5 zu 1 in Regensburg und
liegt in der Tabelle nur noch einen
Punkt hinter Heidenheim der Kampf um den
Aufstieg bleibt also spannend und im
ersten Sonntagsspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga trennen sich der
abstiegsgefährdete VfB Stuttgart und
Leverkusen 1:1 der VfB jetzt Vorletzter
in der Tabelle Leverkusen 7 und das
deutsche Eishockey-Team hat bei der WM
auch das zweite Spiel gegen einen
starken Gegner knapp verloren nach der
Niederlage gegen Schweden unterlag die
Mannschaft Gastgeber Finnland mit drei
zu vier kurz vor Ende des zweiten
Drittels hatte John Jason patakar den
Ausgleich zum 3 zu 3 erzielt sieben
Minuten Verschluss der Partie gelangen
dem Titel Verteidiger und Olympia sogar
Finnland dann aber doch noch der siegtre
ffer
und morgen geht's für Deutschland gegen
die USA ist auch ein dicker Brocken
und so wird das Wetter morgen am
Vormittag im Norden noch häufig Sonne am
Mittag verbreitet Schauer und Gewitter
im Süden mehr Wolken als Sonne und
häufig Regen 14 bis 22 Grad
begrüßt sie um 21.45 zum heute-journal